yo i kid you not i just refreshed the
page on the channel that we got this
trailer from
it did not say mechagodzilla in eyes it
said something about eric what did it
say
military aircraft trailer is what it
originally said one media channel was
like
oh
all right guys gotta make this quick
because uh we gotta pull an all-nighter
tonight for
one division i gotta get like at least
an hour nap in before that
occurs but godzilla versus kong i hear
an awesome new trailer has come
out for the monster epic wearing
olivia's team godzilla shirt i have
declared my stance on the fight
oh you can't pick him godzilla right you
gotta play the middle
no i am not neutral i am team godzilla
all right i'm team godzilla too if you
are team kong
i'm a okay with you being team cops
absolutely that's just the team we're at
right now either way
it's gonna be a fun epic adventure
as your ape goes down yeah you would
suck on the sweet taste of
defeat i think most of our audience
though when voting
went for god this is just how we make
ourselves feel better what if people
were like
screw you guys unsubscribe don't you
talk about
your monster politics out of my videos
don't choose aside even though that's
what this is all about
whoa off to a good start godzilla's
[Music]
all right all right
don't get me wrong we're trying to see
cog in action too man
[Music]
maverick dude
wow what was he doing there
there can't be two alpha types
oh do you see that what is that was that
mecca godzilla
that the mech i'm just letting you guys
know too
if it's that same company that's been
claiming us over
stupidest [ __ ] like that tom cruise
video and times there's no music if it's
them who claims this video the music
will be
edited all right
gonna be edited out i'm just telling you
guys that if it's them
because another company will let the
copyright claim sit but if it's them
not no satisfaction not for them oh yeah
that is
give it to me now in the reflection of
the eyes it has like an iron giant thing
going on
i am not a gun but no you could you
could even see some of its other body
part here oh
that is so cool yeah they're saying
there can't be two alpha titans and they
go in there with a mechagodzilla oh you
know it's mega godzilla
but damn these little extra flourishes
of shots are just they just every
shot just lands a hit doesn't it man
even then fighting underwater you just
feel like kong putting up the best fight
he could possibly do
underwater in godzilla's territory dude
well to watch kong just like
throw fists down on the ground and what
is that hong kong or something i think
somebody in the comments said all right
guys well leave your thoughts down below
which team are you a-okay whichever team
you're on
either way i'm excited to watch both of
these titans duke it out subscribe click
the notification bell hit the like
button
got a bunch of other godzilla vs kong
videos on the channel catch you guys
soon